In the previous video, we understood how
to find the face on the surface of this box of cereal,
finding the faces on each of the six surfaces
of the box and then gathered them.
In this clip I will do this again,
but I'll do it by visualizing the box's unfolding.
The way I look at a box break
like this, is the following - what happens if you need to
to cut the box and then open it?
What am I talking about?
This is what we could imagine,
that we cut the box and the incision can be ...
Let's see, I can cut it here in the back.
I can make a cut right there,
I can cut it ...
I can cut it as follows.
If I do it this way, this top cover
will open so that he can go out
as follows. Then I can, too
to make a cut for this country.
I can make a cross section there
and I can make a cut right here.
Now this country will go forward,
and I can do the same thing
with this country here.
Then it can go forward,
and the back ...
I can draw it.
So I will also have a cut.
I will draw it as a dashed line because
it is assumed that you do not see this incision.
And the corresponding cut of this
on the country we can not see,
we can draw a bit more accurately.
The corresponding cut will be right here in the back.
Right there in the back and then we have a section right here.
So, what will happen,
if we unfold all this?
Well, we will have,
we will have the front of the box.
I will try to draw it as clearly as I can.
The front of the box looks like this.
We will have this top cover that looks like this,
if we have to unfold it completely.
We have these two side covers.
So it's a side cover.
This is a side cover.
And this is one more, this country is stretched right here.
Then we'll have the bottom of the box.
The bottom of the box will look like this.
The bottom of the box.
And then we have the back of the box.
The one that will be connected to the bottom.
We did not cut that.
And so we have the back of the box.
The back of the box will look like this.
So we got it.
We did the unfolding.
This will happen if
make the incisions I spoke about,
and then unfold the box. It will look like this.
Now how can we use this loophole to find the face on the surface?
We just have to find it now
face on the surface of this figure.
How are we going to make it?
We know a lot about the dimensions.
We know that this width is here,
that it's ten centimeters.
Ten centimeters from here to here.
We know the height, actually
the whole distance from here upwards.
Since the height of the box is 20 centimeters,
this will be 20 centimeters.
And you have another 20 centimeters
right here.
And here, in the same way.
And then you have, look at the depth of the box
is three centimeters, so it's three centimeters.
Three centimeters and then it's three centimeters.
So what is the person,
actually let me just make an area first.
What is the face of this whole area,
which shade with this blue color?
Well, it's ten centimeters ...
I will use a color that you can see much easier.
It's ten centimeters wide, ten centimeters.
How much is the height?
20 plus 3, plus 20, plus 3.
This will be 40 plus six. That's 46 centimeters.
This is this blue area.
This will be 460 square centimeters.
460 square centimeters and now only
we have to find the face of the two covers.
So that cover here
is 20 inches by 3 centimeters.
So it's 60 centimeters square.
And so 60 centimeters square,
or 60 square centimeters.
And then that lid will have exactly the same face.
Another 60 square centimeters.
60 square centimeters and collect everything together.
We deserve fanfare.
We get ... This will be
580 square centimeters.
Which is exactly the same thing we got in the other video,
in which we did not use a loophole.
However, it is good to be able to do it in both ways.
To be able to visualize the unfolding,
or you can look at it and think
for the different countries, even for those who
may not be visible.